talk to us about that everest photo
all right paul this you know i it was
used in the wrong reason
it was used misutilized by the media
people
and some of them didn't even give the
credit and i'm super upset
i will tell you the the exact
thing because i have been there this is
this is my world you know
every year 20 000 people climb one block
is the highest mountain in europe more
than twenty thousand people
and then if you try to capture the few
people of like twenty thousand people
how how much q you're gonna
see on mont blanc well unlike mount
everest mon blanc has got so many
different opportunities
it has got different weather conditions
and
there are so many like you know i would
say
um opportunities of getting to the
summit at different time interval
and it's not a thousand meters it's only
you know like five thousand but everest
only like 1200 per minute where you sit
and that number is
relatively low it wasn't any bigger than
2014 2013 11 or anything else
and a lot of people were commenting
about this without
knowing about everest you know they were
like oh it's a tourist and all it's like
no it's not you know you got to go into
the mountain
you go to accommodate for almost two
months you got to come
through this kumbu icefall that can kill
you at any time then forget the lotze
wall it's like
1.6 miles you know and it's about 55
degrees
you got to climb that then into the
south coal then you got to climb the
everest
have you done that if you haven't then
please
don't comment now coming into that
picture
a lot of this kind of people were over
there and that season
because of the whole weather condition
there was only one good day towards the
end of the season
and of course if you have put your time
effort money
some people have sold their house you
want to go for that you want to take
that opportunity
so everybody took that opportunity it's
a it's a human thing and don't say that
oh it's a tourist no man you know if you
haven't
been there and if you haven't done that
you know yeah
and that's what it offset me because you
know people use it for the wrong reason
you know if you have crime everest in in
whatever way
then you can talk but then again be true
to yourself
you know and then a lot of people ask me
oh everest is a lot easier and it's like
no
really man because i spoke with reinhold
messner who climbed all this in a
thousands without oxygen
if you remove all the support manpower
the the the therapist and everybody else
everest is still the hardest mountain to
climb you cannot even go through the
kumbaya so forget you know
lots of wall so if you don't know enough
knowledge
don't talk about it guys that's all i
want to say
it was interesting that that's your
viewpoint on it and that's the reason
i mean why did you take the photo for
that reason just because it was
interesting and impressive
no no no no i took the reason because i
was trying to climb everest and let's
say in just six hours
my previous record was 10 hours 15
minutes which i had broken accidentally
i didn't even knew that i was just like
going in my normal place
so when i said i was going to broke my
world record by like you know let's say
almost half because at this point i'm
conscious
so but then i got stuck in the traffic
and all that i was just like
somebody yes i'm a man of my word and if
somebody questioned me like okay you
said that but you didn't do it
people are always like that man you will
find people like this and i would say
okay
it's good you say me that but then this
is the reason i it was just for my
evidence
i understand you made this like negative
haters shot their mouth but then
it was used in other purpose brother but
hey man that's so interesting that
in your opinion is someone who's more
qualified than pretty much everybody on
the planet to talk about going up and
down mountains quickly
you're still saying everest's the
hardest mountain to climb on the planet
if it's unsupported
it's still even supported incredibly
difficult
the reason that the mountain on that day
was so heavily populated is because of
the
um backlog of people you get when they
do a push to base camp one base camp two
and then they finally go
up and down in a day you only had a
short window of weather
and then yeah yeah it gets flipped
because the message that came across to
me
as a normal member of the public was
look at
these rich lazy
adventure wannabes who are paying
probably cheap local
sherpas to carry all of their stuff up
you know what it reminded me of
this is what i thought when i first saw
all of the news stories have you seen
those images
of people who've shot lions in
um parks in africa and stuff like that
and there's always
it's always a rich american businessman
he's a bit fat he's sweating
and yeah you've got this this kind of
fat
picture of modern day excess
human next to a really proud gracious
animal
that someone else is tracked and he's
killed and it gave me the same sensation
as that
it made me think have we commodified
have we made so commercialized
the tallest supposedly most difficult
mountain on the planet
and what you're saying is that it's
quite the opposite it's still incredibly
hard to do
and for anyone that actually understands
the way that you do a push up the
mountain
this queue of people was inevitable
because they'd done the hard work and
this was their one opportunity to get to
the there was one opportunity
and then who wouldn't take that you know
so if you don't
if you haven't done that and if you
haven't been there and you could have
done you know
yeah some people even commented it
because they climb in in different era
at different times
it's still the same if at that point
when these people had climbed
and there were there were other climbers
up to this enormous size because
of the of the education because of the
knowledge that people knew that then
you would still be in that same position
it's just the time you know it's
changing because now people know what it
is and people know what it takes
just because you have been there for the
first time doesn't mean like
it was so like hard still you got to
climb that mountain
either somebody run to like full
marathon in two hours or whatever it is
you still have to run that marathon
still you have to do it you cannot just
say
oh one person did full marathon and he's
the first man to do it
or negative brother if people are still
doing full marathon now
still you got to claim that achievement
because you run that same distance
be broad about the thinking people and
uh
let's stop being so like
i don't know you know people just always
pointing this one and like
judgmental negative energy yeah you know
we have come into this world where
this is a time to adjust this is the
time where i feel like
it's not about the race it's not about
you know which national you are from
it's not about
now this thing's gonna change it's about
the human risk and
now coming into this my topic this is
gonna happen because with the climate
change with the global warming
if we all as a human being don't work
together
we're not gonna extinct we just we're
just gonna disappear
so this is where you know the things are
happening naturally brother you know
like
where you know it's not about you know
before it was
if you see the world again back and then
people were like about
the rest people were from that is
changing now slowly and then now we are
changing for a reason
we are changing for for our survival as
well
so in every areas that we need to be
broader thinking in a human i guess
was there not a story
associated with your photo to do with
people leaving
rubbish on the mountain no it wasn't
thank god okay but do you know do you
know what i'm talking about i've just
made this
yeah no no so i think you know there are
a lot of you know rubbish and stuff on
on the big mountains and all and
you know sometimes you know people are
so tired and they don't do it but then
i think now you know or also some people
probably didn't knew the extremity of
of that that that incident
and that probably didn't know how much
it's gonna affect the world by leaving a
trust there
but now everybody is getting educated
you know people probably you know used
to leave the electricity on in the house
even though if they are not there but
now
people are getting educated so if they
turn the electricity off they don't do
food waste you know at least some people
are trying
and then it's exactly same i think that
the education has
the awareness has gone a bit wider now
and of course all these people love that
love the mountains and and
as we progress towards this in the next
generation
everybody will start cleaning this up
and i think
nobody is there as a bad human i would
say and it's just about the the
perspective
we all want to do the good in life i
don't think anybody in the world want to
be known for like super bad
in a man i don't know if there is this
maybe
point whatever percent but everybody
wants to be happy
everybody wants to be good person so i
think we are a good person so i think we
will start cleaning all that up in the
in the future
all my expedition that we run we're
gonna if there is there's a capacity
with with
our guides and all we'll bring it down
and uh
and it's not like the effort of one
person we all have to do together and
as long as everybody put everything what
they do
as as a core messes are you like we have
to look after our earth in whatever
way we do then then it's fair
and then and i think the whole thing
with um i just recently was you know sir
david
attenborough you know you know you know
the witness is in a
statement and it's very simple you know
we don't have to be super like you know
like
you know wrong or super like you know
like i don't know
extreme about this but as long as it's
practical and as long as we whatever
decision we make we put you know our
home as an earth
as a core into that decision making that
we are making
will make the whole difference and and
that could be small from like
people like us to the politicians to the
billionaires everybody if everybody
plays their part
we're smiling so what
what did you see into in terms of
climate change
what effects can you see on the mountain
so from my own eyes i was on amazon in
2014
at that point when we were at someone
you know we could
melt the snow and we can cook our food
and drink
i went there again in 2018 and then
you know what there was no snow anything
else and we had to carry like 20 liters
of water from the base camp
and 20 liters is 20 kg and when you had
to carry that of that altitude just
because
you know the global warming is happening
and all that
it kicks you man then the other incident
was i was in dallas
so the alligator is known as the white
mountain because it snows
all the time it's the world's seventh
highest mountain
i was there in 2014 and last year when i
went you know during the
the bremen project possible the whole
glacier was like melting
and and i saw it from my own eyes
and that was a bit really sad moment
brother and hence why you know like last
year i said i was going to raise the
awareness about climate change but now
as a nymphs as a person i'm acting on it
you know i cannot change the world but
then i can change in my
lifestyle i can do whatever i can do in
order to like you know
be more sustainable
you